three hours of the debut of the 24th
season of The Bachelor on ABC returns
tonight at 8:00 Eastern Time The
Bachelor Peter Webber is now in the
pilot seat if you will and the host is
Chris Harrison here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you good to see you man
Happy New Year happy New Year to you too
when it when does that why don't we when
one is the date by which you can't say
happen January 15th 5:30 p.m.
[Laughter]
you're a jerk if like January 16th day
happy new year that's way too long but
up until then we're fine we're fine
I've got another week yeah to do that
what if I see you in a week we've
already taken care of it though no now
we've already done done yeah we got to
move on and it's awful you only get one
as well right so one up until January
15th and then you got to move on right
so you're the perfect person I know
these rules you know what because it's I
don't it's kind of like baseball there's
unwritten rule it's true this is the
unwritten rules of how many times you
could say happy new yeah because if you
do it again I throw at you that's right
you know also to your your diehard golf
guy when you were talking me in the
commercial break about what went down at
Kapalua
that's crazy last night I know what by
which point because you play a lot of
golf probably with a lot of people you
just get introduced yeah by which point
are you not allowed to ask somebody that
you're just starting to play golf with
it you've never met their name again
what that's that's a great question it
really is like this second hole after
the second hole you've already box green
tee box like the green green of the
second hole your pot committed you
cannot have together because you've
warmed up you've teed up you've played
about 30 45 minutes together you've had
a few probably intimate conversations
about family friends that kind of stuff
you can't go back a big what yeah and
then you just gotta hope you're in a
foursome where someone goes hey rich
good shot let's rich that's right and a
scorecard exactly I've been there and
I've done that but even if you you it's
a great question hey man I've always had
these these questions like but to me
it's the third tee box but you always
have to still acquire the names of
everybody anyway because one time
I was playing golf this back way back
when it was in ESPN I got hooked up with
a couple was me and a buddy and we got
hooked up with a married couple and
whose names just escaped me on the sixth
hole know when I missed like a
three-foot putt because I was too short
I said hit it Sally
and then she goes what say that again
Wow her name was never to be Sally
you're up first yeah Chris Harrison here
on the Rich Eisen show okay so you've
seen a ton of awkward long breakups in
your day where does Jason Garrett in the
Cowboys rank for you that would have
been it's up it's up there in the
18-year history of me seeing love and
breakup has been and in a tough one
because look he's a good guy he sure is
by the way a good ball coach in an NFL
quality coach it's just one of those
things and you've been in whether it's
TV sports no matter what there is a
point in time yes when you just got a
cut and you got it make a change and
yeah you know when you have the horses
and clearly they do have the horses you
can't tell me they don't have as good a
players as Minnesota or Tennessee that
are now deep into the playoffs so they
have the stars they have the power they
have the line they got it all what's
left well it's it's the organization
it's the coach you've got to make a
change and I hate to say that because
you know we all are so glib about
coaching changes and all that these are
still people's lives Jason Garrett has
his life set up in Dallas he's a good
dude and he's a good guy and he's a good
coach and I obviously he'll probably be
picked up somewhere but Jerry had to
make a change as loyal as Jerry Jones is
he had to turn this thing around well
I'm now I feel bad for being glib in the
way that I've set up the question said
but but you know all that now that there
were got that other way it was weird
last week and the fact that that that
they never officially said that we're
done here aren't there and look you know
the NFL standards like once you announce
it aren't there steps you have to
officially take and so I think like not
doing it just allows them to but they
still did interview player coach
including marvin lewis and they are the
first team to name a new coach even
after it was that last i really I would
love to eventually talk to them and how
well Mike McCarthy must have sold them
in the room because there was the
interview
that apparently was supposed to go just
the afternoon/evening he ends up
spending the night this et allegedly at
Jerry's house does he have a window
Jerry and Mike McCarthy went to the
fantasy suite four times later they're
engaged
Mike McCarthy's a closers what I perform
yeah so apparently that must been one
hell of an interview had the right
things to say right he was there for the
right reason stayed overnight yeah
that's the report from Schefter
basically that would be like tonight yes
Peters in the driveway women show up he
just walks off with one of them they
spend the night together and game over
tomorrow well what would happen to the
rest of the season of The Bachelor makes
for really bad television some more
weeks to go so you're saying Jerry
should have really stretched this out
well you know what no you still have to
there's still there is no like Senior
Bowl to get ready for a bachelor so you
got to like to actually get your dumb
joke someone was asking my opinion and
I've heard a lot of people talking this
morning about this about you know what
about Urban Meyer what about Lincoln
Riley and you know this happens to the
bachelor and bachelorettes often they're
looking for the sexy pic okay know the
guy the bad boy the guy they can change
ask Hannah from last season yes what do
you get when you get the guitar playing
bad boy
not great you know it doesn't always
have to be sexy safe solid right really
successful not such a bad thing right
Mike McCarthy is safe solid successful
and he's also a change
so Peter Weber he's the Peter Weber of
this equation he's the Ben Higgins Peter
Weber and that works out for you yeah I
love by the way this is Megan Riley's
the guy with the guitar it's right he's
that we don't need that yeah sure it's
fun but is it gonna work out that's your
your that's your school - I do like no
look he would have been I would've been
the combination of your of your bringing
oh you and the Cowboys together we did
that once with Barry Switzer worked out
for a second
he was the Peter Weber around the bad
boy yeah and then he jumped the fence
and ran away I like that I like the
McCarthy peg I think and from what I
have also understood allegedly he does
not have to keep anybody so he can come
in and bring in his own people yeah and
he's gonna have he's gonna have free
rein which you have to have if you're
gonna turn this thing around yeah I mean
that's the thing it cuz in terms of the
idea of Jerry Jones deciding to I'm
gonna bring in the new general manager
I've been saying for weeks here that's
just not the way he wants to do it I
mean he has everything then the guy
literally has everything that he wants
except for that one more trophy in the
case and the way that he wants to do it
he wants to do with his son Steven and
he wants to do it the way that he wants
to do it the same way that if you have a
fantasy football team you're not farming
out 3x and the week to week stuff that's
just some other person cuz that's the
way you're supposed to win and the
pressures due just to because times
ticking I mean he's not getting any
younger either and so is this his last
head coaching pick right and you know
that his last run well as you said with
his family right um with Charlotte with
with Steven with all the kids there yeah
this is kind of a big this is a big step
for him and so obviously McCarthy must
have really wooed him in the room we'll
see how it works out obviously though
coming up in the 2020 season Chris
Harrison here on the Rich Eisen show so
when you when you do meet Peter again
for the first time after what happened
to him do you have like a heart-to-heart
guy talk like away from the cameras and
stuff like that before you you start
rolling yeah this is the the first odd
season where we have a guy or girl that
actually grew up he's a neighbor of mine
and yeah he literally is his parents
house is a half a mile from my house and
so he grew up he go he went to high
school where my kids now go to high
school he grew up in the shadow of the
bachelor mansion he used to drive by it
you know thousands of time going to and
from the beach so it's really
interesting he's been a fan of this show
and watching it happen in his lifetime
in his real life and so it's been really
interesting to to go through it with him
but yeah we had some heart-to-hearts of
you know how he's gonna go through this
what its gonna be like and and even
throughout we became really good friends
and and he had a tuft
he is a tough time with making really
tough decisions and breaking people's
hearts and be in the de mean guy right
and he kind of kicked the can down the
road a couple of times and that just you
know Kenny can exacerbate a situation of
like you you got to make some decisions
here
right and then you know obviously what
happened him last year for those who
don't know well I could tell you Hanna
comes back tonight okay and but she
doesn't just come back once well what
are we doing at Peter what are we doing
here man when when you see not the first
the first is a very good emotional sweet
scene isn't she broke she broke the
guy's heart yeah but wait till she comes
back later in the show tonight it is
unlike honey any conversation I've ever
seen the tension between the two of them
yeah it's the windmill anywhere in the
picture it is oh my god
yeah for those who don't know I mean
you've been living under a rock Peter
and airline pilot and Hannah went into
the windmill and they had sex four times
[Laughter]
trade table in the upright position
sure what is the talk like with you and
your kids when you're having the talk is
this well my kids are eleven eight and
six
[Music]
yeah let me tell you about the pilot in
the windmill a lot of metaphors like
what the hell is dad talking about man I
would talk to you but here's the
bachelors Chris Harrison Chris come on
out that is something I should offer is
that on Chris Harrison official com that
is my website where yeah you can now I'm
gonna add that I will officiate weddings
I I do videos and all that but now also
offered on the website I will come have
the talk with your kids that's actually
a great service
it really would be because I did I like
I have two children I'd my son and my
daughter they're 18 and 16 so greater
well past those talks they're now
they're now talking to me and teaching
me things but I I felt like I kind of
crushed it on the talk okay yeah you did
yeah I'm very different and this might
be a double-standard sexist wherever the
talks were very different from my son
and my daughter okay because the
responsibilities are a little different
of course they are yeah but you when you
crushed it I mean like do you walk away
going on I'll never forget when you sit
down because it's really awkward it's
just as awkward for you as it is the
kids right and you're just like I told
my son is like Josh like this is
happening so just just sit there and
this is gonna happen this is gonna be
over as we're ripping a band-aid off
we're gonna get through this website as
a way to kind of connect with bachelor
nation I've had people ask me for years
you know will you officiate my wedding
will you help me with a proposal will
you you know all this stuff and I've
never really had a way to really
honestly offer it to the masses and so
for better or for worse I have and now
I'm in actually in the process now me
and the team of setting up doing my
first weddings for bachelor nation
because that's where you could not
attend the Rams Cowboys Ryan last year
and because re-write lion Dyke was
getting married and you officiated yeah
and this year I missed the Cowboys
playoff game that's true I told you
though I really felt good this this
weekend because and I hate to say this
but I didn't have to watch the Cowboys
lose in week one because look we were we
were leaking oil the wheels were coming
off right did we really want to go into
the playoffs you know sometimes it you
you don't want your team to make it yeah
even when they could and maybe could
reverse things because you're saving
yourself the heartbreak this is that
relationship that it's it's over but
you're heading into the holidays right
and you can't break up before
right and New Year's and so you can't
his years you're still just going
through the motions we just needed to
rip that oldest move and move on the
analogies between the Cowboys and the
NFL and the playoffs and the batter
there's so many of them do you have any
questions for Chris cuz I know you just
are gonna go down this wormhole phone
lines kids coming by the way Brockman's
know I'm really excited for tonight I'm
excited to see Peter and no way you know
how he his mindset heading into this
into this season and so I'm just excited
for the three yeah he's a great dish I
went flying with him okay we went on a
little golf adventure okay and this is
the great thing about having a pilot we
were flying down to our friends at
Callaway actually there you go and Peter
said well can I just fly us in it yeah
yeah I mean no 405 and so we got a plane
a much smaller plane than I had heard we
were getting into a twin-engine a twin
prop turns out that was in the shop and
so we got in a single prop and I mean it
was like we were sitting in this chair
together it was tight but a very
competent very very good very good
all right yeah so what's he better at is
it flying or the windmill apparently to
Hannah
the windmill cockpit references the
aviation references the windmill
references just know we're wearing him
out tonight okay you're getting him
almost three hours yeah you're getting
him tonight there's three a lot Chris
Harrison official comm at Chris B
Harrison on Twitter and Instagram of
what was what was the best part of the
Golden Globes night last night let's
dive in with you not trying to get there
obviously security heightened because of
things going on and apparently
internationally in this in our country
and so it was a nightmare getting in but
it was a good that was a great night it
was a great night the parties are always
good but think about the globe's yes it
starts as a cocktail party and then all
the parties are at the Beverly Hilton
now if you if you don't know the right
there when you go to the Oscars or
whatever it's all over Holly
from here to San Diego and so it's a
mess trying to get to stuff but
everybody is in the same lobby last
night so you're walking from Party to
party and you're like oh there's
shirley's and oh there's Brad Pitt and
everyone's just kind of walking around
it's really it's a great vibe see now
the only analogy I could make is with
the sports Emmys
the you know the Tom isn't Hanks it's
Brennaman that's at least gonna go Brady
but but where it used to be they used to
have it in a hotel in Times Square and
there were open bars all over the place
and it was it's great it was awesome and
you would see people you know from
previous years and friends and
colleagues and you'd get together nobody
paid attention what the hell is going on
the stage so they now hold it in an
auditorium with no drinks no food and
it's just the absolute pits yeah well
even I mean if you pay attention last
night Ricky Gervais so when he comes on
and he's hosted like nobody's listening
I mean everyone's still right I don't
know if that style of hosting is holding
up anymore
obviously it was his last time and when
he went in to burn Rome down but yeah
the I hate everybody and I don't care
mentality of hosting is not a thing
anymore dude that doesn't hold up we
need to band together as hosts of
anything Chris okay I host what I host
you host what you host all of the hosts
need to get together is right now award
shows are being host less yeah last
night's awards show is by a host who
flat out said I don't care you know we
can't have that we need a hashtag which
is what hosts our people - yeah
something like that we need we need a
movement a coaster people to 20 20
something we need something that will
start a movement come together create a
to get Probst and bergeron on the line
dan Patrick now yes yes we all have to
band together and make sure that hosts
are we're still people - we are yeah
that's again crispy Harrison on Twitter
and Instagram I can't wait for the batch
but tonight love when you come in always
a pleasure
always a pleasure to know you got it
Happy New Year same team
I can't wait to say that to you next
week just a left I'm one week from today
24th season of The Bachelor three hours
tonight 8:00 Eastern Time and Chris
Harrison official comm check out all
that good stuff including the soon to be
added he'll tell the birds and the bees
talk hash tag don't go anywhere
our number three Mike Pereira the head
of NFL officials from back of the day
now with Fox in your phone calls at 8:00
for for 204 for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app